if a man does not love Solitude he will
not love freedom for it is only when he
is alone that he is really free
everyone takes the limits of his own
vision for the limits of the world
a pessimist is an optimist in full
possession of the facts
[Music]
politeness is the human nature what
warmth is to wax
[Music]
truth is most beautiful undraped
in Action a great heart is the chief
qualification in work a great head
honor has not to be won
it must only not be lost
foreign
[Music]
hits a Target no one else can hit genius
hits a Target no one else can see
[Music]
Ordinary People merely think how they
shall spend their time
a man of talent uses it
[Music]
one should use common words to say
uncommon things
hope is the confusion of the desire for
a thing with its probability
to overcome difficulties is to
experience the full Delight of existence
[Music]
willpower is to the mind like a strong
blind man who carries on his shoulders a
lame man who can see
feel Envy as human to save her
schadenfreude is devilish
[Music]
how shall a man be proud when his
conception is a crime his birth a
penalty his life of Labor and his death
a necessity
[Music]
each day is a little life
nature shows that with the growth of
intelligence comes increased capacity
for pain
sleep is the interest we have to pay on
the capital which is called in at death
if you want to know your true opinion of
someone watch the effect produced in You
by the first sight of a letter from him
[Music]
almost all of our sorrows spring from
our relations with other people
[Music]
we forfeit three quarters of ourselves
in order to be like other people
[Music]
Every Nation ridicules other nations and
all are right
it is difficult to find happiness within
oneself but it is impossible to find it
anywhere else
the greatest of volleys is to sacrifice
health for any other kind of happiness
a man can be himself only so long as he
is alone
[Music]
the clear gain to sacrifice pleasure in
order to avoid pain
the closing years of life are like the
end of a masquerade party when the masks
are dropped
a sense of humor is the only Divine
quality of man
[Music]
happiness consists in frequent
repetition of pleasure
wealth is like sea water the more we
drink the thirstier we become the same
is true of Fame
the two enemies of human happiness are
pain and boredom
the safest way of not being miserable is
not to expect to be happy
[Music]
money is human happiness in the abstract
[Music]
life is a constant process of dying
[Music]
we seldom think of what we have but
always of what we lack
[Music]
every possession and every happiness is
but lent by chance for an uncertain time
and may therefore be demanded back the
next hour
[Music]
foreign
passes through three stages first it is
ridiculed second it is violently imposed
third it is accepted as being
self-evident
[Music]
in our monogamous part of the world to
marry means to have one's rights and to
double one's duties
[Music]
there is no doubt that life is given to
us not to be enjoyed but to be overcome
to be got over
[Music]
the person who writes for fools is
always sure of a large audience
what people commonly call fate is mostly
their own stupidity
no one writes anything worth writing
unless he writes it entirely for the
sake of the subject
[Music]
Wicked thoughts and worthless efforts
gradually set their mark on the face
especially the eyes
[Music]
mostly it is loss which teaches us about
the worth of things
it is only at the first encounter that a
face makes its full impression on us
[Music]
the word of man is the most durable of
all material
it's the nice cities that make the
difference fate gives us the hand and we
play the cards
a port or philosopher should have no
fault to find with his age if it only
permits him to do his work undisturbed
in his own corner
if we were not also interested in
ourselves life would be so uninteresting
that none of us would be able to endure
it
[Music]
to be alone is the fate of all great
minds a fate deplored at times but still
always chosen as the less Grievous of
two evils
[Music]
boredom is just the reverse side of
Fascination both depend on being outside
rather than inside a situation and one
leads to the other
[Music]
great men are like eagles they build
their nest on some lofty solitude
the bad thing about all religions is
that instead of being able to confess
their allegorical nature they have to
conceal it
no roles without a thorn but many a
thorn without a rose
[Music]
the difficulty is to try to teach the
multitude that something can be true and
untrue at the same time
[Music]
conscience accompanies Every Act with a
comment you should act differently
although its true sense is you could be
other than you are
religion is the Masterpiece of the art
of animal training for it trains people
as to how they shall think
men are the Devils of the earth and the
animals are the tormented Souls
after your death you will be what you
were before your birth
life swings like a pendulum backward and
forward between pain and boredom
[Music]
the more intelligent a man is the less
mysterious existence seems to him
the only Freedom that exists is of a
metaphysical character
in the physical world freedom is an
impossibility
[Music]
hatred is an affair of the heart
contempt that of the head
[Music]
it is with Trifles and when he is off
guard that a man best Reveals His
character
thank you
[Music]
will minus intellect constitutes
vulgarity
[Music]
men are by Nature merely indifferent to
one another
but women are by Nature enemies
[Music]